david de ici rideau hall à ottawa on te
voit et nuit david quel bonheur d'être
avec toi dans cette dans cet événement
on est tous très impressionnés par le
travail que tu fais par la générosité
avec laquelle tu partages cette
expérience merci d'être là
bonjour je m'appelle sahara pour qu'il
vous décrire le sentiment d'être en
microgravité bonjour serra mais en fait
c'est un petit peu comme être dans une
piscine peut-être tu vois je peux me
laisser flotter comme ça et voilà je
touche à rien pendant quelques semaines
on a un pull rose de sensations que
notre estomac flotte à l'intérieur un
peu comme quand c'est du sceau d'un
trait au plongeon pendant que tu tombes
ce sentiment là que tout remonte après
ça fait un peu une congestion parce que
le sang remonte à la tête
donc il ya quelques sentiments étranges
comme ça mais c'est surtout le fait qu'
on peut on peut se déplacer en volant
c'est ça qui est vraiment incroyable
bonjour je m'appelle et milliards et je
vous le voulez vous demander est ce que
c'est possible de voir la pollution de
l'espace comme par exemple le lait
plastique dans les océans
j'ai essayé de voir les la mer de
plastique dans l'océan puis j'ai pas
réussi à l'avoir mais peut-être que je
veux je regarde plus attentivement mais
en général oui on peut voir subtilement
des effets de la pollution autour des
grandes villes on peut voir une espèce
de smaug
et puis évidemment on peut prendre des
photographies par exemple des glaciers
où des icebergs ou des aides et des
zones polaires et comparer avec des
vieilles photographies et voir qu'il ya
la fonte des glaces se propage on peut
voir l'effet de la déforestation un
autre fait de la main de l'homme
donc il ya des effets subtils qu'on peut
voir sur sur notre belle planète
je m'appelle simon et ma question à 15
heures d'expérience ou recherches faites
vous dans l'espace ou alors tout à
l'heure j'ai décrit une expérience
médicale mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
gens d'expérience
par exemple un peu plus tôt j'entraîne
organiser notre jardin on a on essaie de
faire pousser des plantes dans l'espace
pour pouvoir un jour se rendre sur mars
est la nourriture qu'on va produire nous
mêmes par exemple on peut faire de la
recherche en biologie moléculaire faire
de la recherche en pharmacologie la
recherche en science des matériaux et de
la recherche en astrophysique qui se
fait ici beaucoup de recherches en
psychologie humaine de la recherche ou
sur tous les recherches plus
technologique sur comment arriver à
survivre dans l'espace comment améliorer
nos systèmes de survie ici donc il ya
toute une série de l'expérience qu'on
fait à bord des centaines qui ont cours
en ce moment des milliers depuis début
de la station et tous assad est retombé
sur terre
c'est ça qui est fantastique avec la
recherche spatiale c'est que ça finit
toujours par nous servir à tout le monde
alex et pouvez vous me dire comment as
tu m'entends l'oxygène à la station
spatiale internationale
alors l'oxygène en fait on le fabrique à
bord à partir de l'eau on prend de l'eau
et on se sépare en hydrogène et oxygène
était après ça nous on le respire
évidemment on inspire et ce qui sort de
nos poumons c'est du gaz carbonique et
là on a une autre machine qui prend le
gaz carbonique et le re brise en
morceaux en fait du méthane et de
l'oxygène il redonne donc on essaie
comme ça de faire une boucle ainsi une
boucle fermée
on n'arrive pas à tout tout tout
recycler mais c'est c'est pas mal
efficace évidemment c'est pas comme la
terre en la terre comme ceci est une
boucle d'un recyclage parfaite tout ce
que les animaux les êtres humains
produisent comme gaz carbonique en
consommant d'oxygène
les plantes et les planctons l'app store
bien et nous redonne de l'oxygène est
comme ça en étant une boucle fermée sur
taille à jamais des renouveau car il est
peu de bouteille d'air qui nous sont
envoyées en c'est tout cela qui est
recyclé on est c'est fait la même chose
à bord et un jour si on veut se rendre
sur mars où il habitait il va falloir
maîtriser cette technologie là et
restera à faire ce que la terre fait
pour nous on est très impressionné très
fière de toi et on va continuer à te
suivre dans tes stats nes bravo david
merci beaucoup merci je dis merci
monsieur premier ministre merci tout le
monde
nous avons
[Applaudissements]